Profesora Tamar Gendler:
El tema de hoy es
la cuestión general sobre qué tipo
de persuasión no racional
es legítima para un gobierno,
si es que hemos de aceptar el
argumento de un contrato social,
según hemos estudiado estas
últimas semanas del curso.
Recordarán que,
empezando con el concepto de justicia
de Platón en la República
y siguiendo con el concepto de
estado de naturaleza de Hobbes,
cada uno de nuestros autores ha sugerido
que es por nuestro propio interés,
de manera que apoyaremos estructuras
gubernamentales reflexivamente,
renunciar a algunas libertades
para garantizar una cierta estabilidad.
Mas las limitaciones que hemos
considerado en sesiones anteriores
han sido leyes explícitas.
Versaban sobre las maneras en
que acordamos reglas
que reconocemos como
vinculantes y que apoyamos
porque consideramos razonable acatarlas.
El argumento de Hobbes apela a la
noción del dilema del prisionero,
que es una paradoja de la racionalidad.
Es un problema que surge cuando
los intereses privados
entran en conflicto e
interactúan con incentivos
de manera particular.
Lo que vimos al final de la clase
pasada y lo que veremos en ésta
es cuán complejos somos
los seres humanos.
Tienen, como sabemos de
nuestras otras clases,
no sólo la razón, sino
otras partes del alma
que se ven afectadas por otras cosas
y no sólo por la razón.
Y eso, también, arroja implicaciones
por las que las estructuras
políticas terminan siendo
razonablemente aceptables.
En particular, lo que
analizaremos esta clase es que,
por un lado, en el Estado
ideal de Platón
habría una censura bastante radical
de las representaciones
ficticias permitidas;
y, por otro, lo que dice Cass Sunstein
sobre que uno de los deberes
del gobierno es establecer normas
que afecten, implícitamente,
cómo construye la gente su conducta.
Es adecuado, por tanto,
comenzar el tema de esta clase
con un par de historias.
Historias verdaderas acerca de
historias falsas y sus efectos.
En 1992, más o menos
cuando ustedes nacían,
nació un personaje televisivo de otro
personaje televisivo
llamado Murphy Brown.
No que sea digno de mención.
Lo relevante es que Murphy Brown no
estaba casada por entonces.
Vaya, ni siquiera tenía pareja estable.
El entonces vicepresidente de
Estados Unidos, Dan Quayle,
dio un famoso discurso en San
Francisco, en 1992, donde sostuvo:
"El matrimonio es un asunto moral
que requiere el consenso y la
aprobación social.
"No ayuda que, en plena
televisión abierta, Murphy Brown,
quien supuestamente encarna
la mujer inteligente,
profesional y bien remunerada de hoy,
trivialice la importancia de un
padre al concebir un hijo sola,
llamándolo una mera
decisión personal más".
De hecho, Dan Quayle malinterpretó
lo que sucedió en el programa.
Murphy Brown no tenía, en
efecto, pareja estable
y sí tuvo un hijo sin el apoyo de
una segunda figura adulta,
pero nunca lo llamó una mera
decisión personal.
Estaba en lo cierto al
denunciar que el programa
no retrataba los costos para la
vida de Murphy Brown
ni cómo tendría ella que rehacer su
vida para poder cuidar al niño.
Lo que es interesante, por
supuesto, es que un hombre real,
Dan Quayle, el vicepresidente
real de un país real,
Estados Unidos, haya
llamado la atención
sobre el ficticio nacimiento de un
niño que era hijo de la actriz
que interpretaba a Murphy Brown;
de tal manera que lo vio
como la erosión
de valores importantes.
Más aún, este debate se
convirtió en noticia.
Fue portada de Time.
Estuvo en la primera plana
del New York Post.
"Dan desgarra a Murphy Brown".
El New York Daily News dijo:
"Quayle a Murphy Brown: '¡Golfa!'".
El New York Times publicó un
artículo algunos meses después
cuando, en un acto de enorme
ironía posmoderna,
el personaje de televisión Murphy
Brown le respondió a Dan Quayle,
el vicepresidente real.
Igualmente, el New York Times
sacó un artículo
que comenzaba con el párrafo:
"Casi todos los televidentes
saben que esta noche
Murphy Brown le responde al
vicepresidente Dan Quayle,
quien forzó el tema de los
valores familiares
dentro de la campaña
presidencial de 1992
al criticar al personaje principal
del show, la primavera pasada,
por tener un hijo fuera del matrimonio".
Ésa es la historia número uno.
Ésta es la historia número dos.
Más recientemente, en 2002, la serie
de televisión 24 presentó
a un presidente de los Estados
Unidos de ascendencia africana.
En 2007, la misma serie mostró
a una mujer como presidente.
En 2008, como todos saben,
los dos candidatos punteros
del Partido Demócrata
fueron un hombre de ascendencia
africana y una mujer.
Los comentadores de las elecciones
decían con frecuencia cosas como
ésta, de un blog de Newsweek:
A lo que apunta la disponibilidad de
representaciones ficticias
de un presidente como un varón
de ascendencia africana
o como una mujer es a que jugó un papel
al permitir que ciudadanos
reales en el mundo real
(no gente imaginaria en la TV)
estuviese conceptualmente
abierta a la posibilidad
de un presidente así.
Tanto Dan Quayle como los
comentadores de 24 estaban,
como bien sabrán por sus
lecturas para hoy,
parafraseando a nuestro amigo Platón.
Dan Quayle, en esencia, dijo que
"si queremos que los
guardianes de la ciudad",
o sea, los ciudadanos que están
en posición de gobernar
y elegir líderes, "piensen
que es deshonroso
verse provocados con facilidad en
aras de odiar a alguien"
(léase: es deshonroso tener un
hijo fuera del matrimonio),
entonces no deberíamos permitir
historias sobre los dioses guerreando
y conspirando unos contra
otros", según Platón;
o historias sobre atractivos
personajes en televisión,
según Dan Quayle.
Es decir, haciendo aquello
que queremos prohibir.
Cuando Platón dice: "si queremos que
los guardianes de la ciudad
piensen que es deshonroso verse
provocados con facilidad
en aras de odiar a alguien, no
deberíamos permitir historias
sobre los dioses guerreando y
conspirando unos contra otros",
apunta a lo mismo que Dan Quayle
dos mil años después.
Y lo mismo los comentadores
de Newsweek y otros,
en su discusión sobre la
elección presidencial de 2008,
que estaban encantados con la
ampliación del rango de candidatos
serios que veían como potenciales
líderes de la nación;
ellos también parafraseaban
a Platón, quien,
inmediatamente después de la cita
que acabo de hacer, continúa:
"Si vamos a persuadir a nuestro pueblo
sobre que ningún ciudadano
ha odiado nunca a otro o que
es impío hacerlo,
entonces eso precisamente debemos
contar en nuestra historia".
En las historias,
representaciones ficticias,
experiencias de la
imaginación que se tornan
parte
de la conversación cultural y
que pueden proveer modelos
tanto problemáticos como inspiradores.
Ahora bien, el acertijo que
surge si pensamos
tan sólo en términos de
racionalidad es el siguiente:
¿Cómo puede algo que
sabemos que es ficticio
afectar nuestra conducta y actitudes?
Porque no es que quienes
veían 24 creyesen,
de hecho, que David Palmer era el
presidente de Estados Unidos.
Ni que los televidentes de Murphy Brown
pensaran que el personaje que
hacía Candice Bergen
había tenido realmente un hijo.
La gente sabía muy bien
que eran representaciones ficticias.
Hasta los niños separan muy bien
pretensión de realidad.
Si asistimos a tomar el té con un
niño que sirve té imaginario
en varias tazas de una tetera vacía,
los niños estarán perfectamente de
acuerdo con que las tazas
están llenas en ese contexto simulado.
Mas ningún niño que tenga sed piensa
que sirva de nada beber de
una de esas tazas.
Si juegan con un niño
a hacer galletas de arcilla,
a los niños les molestará si
tratan de morder una.
Por supuesto, también los adultos
tiene la capacidad de distinguir
lo que es meramente
imaginario de lo que es real.
Todos tenemos esa capacidad
inscrita en una parte del alma.
La respuesta al acertijo
que suscitan Platón/Dan
Quayle y los bloggeros
es que la ficción
problematiza afectando
las partes no racionales
del alma de maneras
que no son fácilmente sujeto de
regulación o control racional.
Esta estructura nos resulta familiar,
pues la hallamos en la discusión
sobre las partes del alma.
Sabemos, por nuestra
clase de enero, que,
si me paro sobre una superficie de
cristal sobre el Gran Cañón,
miro hacia abajo y veo el
tremendo río Colorado,
aunque mi racionalidad me
diga que estoy a salvo,
las partes no racionales de mi
alma se ven afectadas
por los estímulos visuales,
y me hace temblar.
Aun si les digo y les convenzo de que
lo que parece ser una caja de
arena para gatos es de hecho
una caja con un pastel de chocolate
cubierto de coco y chiclosos,
aunque la parte racional de
su alma me crea,
será difícil lidiar con
las otras partes.
Y lo mismo pasa con la serie de
acertijos que revisamos
en el contexto de la tradición de
la heurística y el sesgo.
Si les doy la opción
de tomar una bola roja
de un tazón con 9 bolas
blancas y una roja
o de un tazón que contiene 92
bolas blancas y 8 rojas,
aunque la parte racional de su alma
esté perfectamente consciente
de que en una hay 10% de posibilidades
contra 8%, será el caso que,
si los presiono cognitivamente
de manera que su parte racional no
pueda tomar la decisión,
se inclinarán hacia el
tazón con más bolas
en vez de hacia el tazón con
mayor probabilidades.
La razón no es suficiente
para regular las partes no
racionales del alma.
Es decir, volvemos a nuestra
discusión sobre la tentación
y la debilidad de la voluntad.
He aquí a Ulises atado al mástil:
la racionalidad comprometida a
pasar por entre las sirenas,
cosa que no podrá realizar
sin taparse los oídos
para no oír la tentación ni
sin atarse al mástil
para impedir caer en ella.
Platón dice más o menos
esto cuando identifica
aquello de las representaciones
que es problemático.
Dice: "el poeta imitador apela a la
parte inferior del alma".
Recuerden que Platón
sostiene una jerarquía:
razón, espíritu, apetito.
"Él excita, nutre y fortalece
esta parte del alma,
y destruye así la parte racional.
"Constituye malamente el
alma de cada individuo
al gratificar la parte
irracional del alma".
Así, el hecho de que sepamos
que algo es ficción
mediante la parte racional del
alma no basta para prevenir
que nos afecte de otras maneras.
En particular, a Platón le preocupan
tres formas en que la ficción
puede afectar el alma de
manera problemática.
Si bien, y esto es importante, está
dispuesto a dejar pasar una cuarta.
Revisar con detalle esto nos
permitirá entender mejor
la visión platónica.
¿Qué preocupa, pues, a Platón sobre
la capacidad de la ficción
de afectar las partes no
racionales del alma?
Primero que nada,
le preocupa lo mismo que a Dan Quayle.
Es decir, que observar en una
circunstancia particular
una representación ficticia
y tomarlo después como una
posibilidad en la vida
puede llevar a elegir mal
los modelos a seguir.
Aún más le preocupa que,
cuando vemos algo
en un contexto ficticio
y debido a que lo reconocemos
explícitamente como tal,
nos permitimos responder a
eso de manera distinta
a como haríamos si fuese real,
si bien nos afecta tan
profunda y emocionalmente
que cambia nuestras actitudes de
aprobación y desaprobación.
Lo que no le preocupa
(y esto será crucial para el
argumento que me ocupa)
es la imitación lúdica.
Casos en los que no sólo al
nivel de la racionalidad,
sino al de las partes de
nuestro sistema de respuesta
que no están sujetas a la
regulación racional,
nos relacionamos con cierta
distancia al material.
Existe una capacidad disponible en
nosotros, reconoce Platón,
para la imitación lúdica.
Y es el contraste entre
ésta y la cuarta
lo que Platón halla más problemático.
Esto nos ayudará a entender el
núcleo de la visión platónica.
Puesto que lo más
problemático para él
(y aquí haremos algunas
analogías contemporáneas)
son los casos donde la imitación
de figuras imaginarias
más lo habitual de ese tipo de
conductas lleva a aquello
que Aristóteles denuncia con fuerza:
un repertorio desviado de
respuestas automáticas.
Para desentrañar este sutil
argumento platónico,
será útil para nosotros
regresar un poco y recordar
que lo hallamos como una parte dentro
del todo de la República.
Recordarán, entonces, que, al
principio del semestre,
en enero, comenzamos leyendo
las primeras páginas
del libro II de la República de
Platón, donde el personaje Glaucón,
en connivencia con su hermano Adimanto,
desafía a Sócrates a
responder la pregunta:
¿por qué debemos ser justos?
Glaucón y Adimanto presentan,
juntos, tres tipos de argumentos,
tres tipos de opiniones a favor
de la justicia como algo con lo
que no nos comprometemos
por razones intrínsecas, sino
apenas como algo que,
en tanto que contingente,
tiene valor instrumental.
Es famoso que Glaucón da un argumento
que caracteriza la justicia
como el tipo de bien que apreciamos
sólo por lo beneficioso que resulta
para nuestra reputación;
y añade que algo así como el
análisis del dilema del prisionero
es la segunda mejor opción para todos.
Luego, cuenta una historia ficticia (la
historia del anillo de Giges
seguida de la historia sobre
un par de estatuas)
con la intención de
persuadir de otra manera.
Por último, Adimanto
señala la continuidad
entre lo que se representa en el
contexto de las historias ficticias
y lo que se representa en
los dichos comunes.
¿Dónde empieza, pues, el
argumento de Sócrates?
¿Responde directamente a
uno, dos y tres?
¿Enfrenta precisamente
los tres argumentos
que Glaucón y Adimanto han
puesto sobre la mesa?
No.
Lo que hace es introducir un
marco más amplio
para pensar estas cuestiones:
la analogía entre la
persona y la ciudad.
Una discusión subsecuente del
libro II, que no leímos,
acerca de los dos tipos de
ciudades que pueden existir.
Entonces, en el contexto del libro IV,
introduce la división tripartita
de la ciudad y del alma.
Dice él que en la ciudad
ideal hay guardianes,
soldados y trabajadores, como en el
individuo están la razón,
el espíritu y el apetito.
Podrán recordar el
paralelismo que consideramos:
cuando estaba el suelo repleto de nieve,
no había otra forma de
representar a la humanidad
que como un hombre de nieve.
Vimos la manera en que la parte
más pequeña, pero líder,
del alma es la razón.
La media es el espíritu.
Y la más baja es el apetito.
Que corresponden a los guardianes,
soldados y auxiliares, respectivamente.
Ahora bien, para entender la discusión
de los libros III y IV, que
leímos para hoy,
sobre la censura de la poesía,
necesitamos reconocer algo
extremadamente interesante
de lo que sucede a
continuación en el libro II.
Hagan memoria: tenemos el
desafío de Glaucón,
¿por qué debemos de ser justos?
Y la respuesta un tanto
extraña de Sócrates,
que invoca la analogía entre la
ciudad-estado y el alma.
Lo que sucede entonces es
que Sócrates explica
cómo han de ser educados
los guardianes.
Mas el tipo de educación que le importa
es la que reciben las partes no
racionales del alma del guardián.
Lo que pasa aquí es que
Platón reconoce que,
dada su concepción del Estado,
sólo a base de argumentos
(diría Aristóteles),
no basta para volver
buenos a los hombres;
deben cultivarse hábitos.
Así también, sugiere Platón,
debe colocarse la educación
de los guardianes
inmediatamente después de la
discusión sobre la naturaleza
y el valor de la justicia;
es igualmente crucial, cuando
pensamos la estructura del Estado,
tomar en cuenta no sólo las leyes,
sino aquello que regula
mediante la razón.
Sin olvidar las
influencias no racionales.
Dice, pues, Platón, al volcarse sobre
la educación de los guardianes,
que la primera pregunta que
cabe hacerse es:
cuando pensamos en la forma
del Estado ideal,
¿cómo ha de ser la
educación temprana,
el cultivo apropiado del espíritu y
el apetito en los guardianes?
Sólo una vez que la respondamos,
estaremos en posición de pasar
a lo que Platón valora más
en esta discusión:
el cultivo de la razón.
Escuchemos ahora exactamente lo
que Platón tiene que decir
acerca de la educación temprana.
Al señalar esto, quiero traer a cuento
algo que mencioné la clase pasada a
propósito de Nozick y Rawls.
Recordarán que mencioné que,
tanto en el índice de
Teoría de la justicia
como en el de Anarquía,
Estado y Utopía
hay dos referencias a los niños.
Casi no hay discusiones
sobre la educación,
mientras que en Platón la primera cosa
con que empieza la discusión
sobre el Estado ideal es ésta.
¿Qué educación tendrán los
guardianes?, pregunta.
"Saben, ¿no?, que el principio
de cualquier proceso
es lo más importante.
"Especialmente para algo joven y tierno.
"Es en aquel momento que
es más maleable
y adopta mejor cualquier patrón
que se quiera inculcarle.
"¿Deberíamos permitir,
sin ningún cuidado,
que los niños escuchen viejas historias
y asimilen creencias en sus
almas que son opuestas
a lo que deberían asirse
cuando sean mayores?"
Y, ya que se trata de un diálogo
socrático, su interlocutor responde:
"Claro que no".
Sócrates continúa:
"Hay que supervisar, entonces, a
los que cuentan historias.
"Habremos de seleccionar aquellas
historias que son buenas y bellas
y rechazar aquellas que no.
"Nodrizas y madres formarán las almas
de sus niños con historias
en mayor medida de lo que forman sus
cuerpos con sus cuidados".
Hace poco hubo una conversación
sobre este personaje familiar,
el Monstruo Come Galletas, que,
siguiendo preceptos como el que
acaba de hacer Sócrates,
apareció cantando "Las galletas
vienen bien de vez en vez"
y comenzó a salir en videos sobre
alimentación saludable.
Se trata del reconocimiento de que
las tempranas narraciones
juegan un papel extrañamente
formativo en las actitudes
de los jóvenes y de que éstas
pueden cambiar actitudes.
Ésta es la primera
preocupación de Platón.
La idea de que,
si se te presenta un modelo a seguir,
la aceptarás como una manera
razonable de existir.
Cuando el poeta cuenta historias donde
"los héroes realizan actos
terribles e impíos", dice,
son historias dañinas para
quienes las escuchan.
Puesto que "todos se
excusarán cuando sean malos
si se persuaden de que los héroes
han hecho cosas similares.
"Por ello, debemos acallar toda historia
que produzca en un joven alguna
fuerte inclinación"
a hacer algo malo.
Dice Platón: si se permite,
digamos, que un personaje
(real o imaginario)
se porte de una manera particular,
existe el riesgo de que consideres
tu propia conducta a
través de la de aquél.
Aún más peligroso es el hecho de que,
por nuestra complicada
relación con la ficción,
respondamos a algo imaginario de
manera lo suficientemente
diferente como para
distorsionar nuestra
experiencia,
a la vez que lo bastante similar como
para afectarnos implícitamente.
"Consideren", arguye famosamente
Platón en el libro X,
"cuando aun los mejores de
nosotros escuchamos a Homero
o a algún dramaturgo
imitando a los héroes
o contando un largo lamento o
golpeándose el pecho,
lo disfrutamos.
Nos resignamos a seguirlos.
"Simpatizamos con el héroe y nos
tomamos en serio su sufrimiento".
Y lo hacemos, según Sócrates,
incluso cuando ello
contradice la reflexión
que creemos que deberíamos tener.
"Cuando alguno de nosotros", prosigue,
"sufre una pérdida privada,
nos damos cuenta de que justo
sucede lo opuesto.
Nos enorgullecemos si somos capaces
de dominar nuestro dolor.
¿Es correcto observar a
alguien comportarse
de manera que consideramos
indigna y vergonzosa,
y disfrutarlo y alabarlo en vez
de sentir repulsión?"
Profundiza y continúa con una serie
de emociones sobre esto mismo.
Dice que, así como podemos hacer
esto debido a la tristeza,
también lo apreciamos en el contexto
de la ficción o el humor bobo.
Apreciamos en el contexto de la ficción
ciertos tipos de conducta indigna.
Sin embargo, dice, ésa
no es exactamente
distancia suficiente para
quedar a salvo.
Nuestra relación con la ficción en
este punto es paradójica.
Por un lado, hay suficientes diferencias
entre la ficción y la realidad
como para que nos dejemos
llevar por las emociones.
La razón dice: es sólo
la imaginación.
No importa cómo respondo a esto.
No es real.
Esto no refleja quién soy.
Mas al grado que existe suficiente
similitud entre las dos,
que la distancia entre ellas se da
apenas al nivel de la razón,
y hay, por tanto, riesgo de contagio.
Tal vez, cabe revisar, de manera más
profunda, el contraste entre los casos
que preocupan a Platón y los que no.
En el libro III, por ejemplo,
concede que hay ciertos casos
en los que está bien relacionarse con
la ficción y la imaginación.
Escribe, hablando de los guardianes,
que, al hallar un personaje indigno,
no estará dispuesto a asemejarse
a un personaje inferior.
Más bien, se avergonzará de ello
a menos que sea en una representación.
Tal parece que (y esto es algo
extremadamente interesante
de los seres humanos) somos
capaces, en algunos contextos,
de asumir una postura
genuinamente lúdica.
En mi sección, cuando actué el
dilema del prisionero,
la novata que hizo de mi oponente
(que está sentada en la tercera fila)
no entendió que estaba jugando,
sino que pensó que lo hacía de
verdad, con lo cual yo,
aparentemente, huí de cada juego.
Ella perdió mucho dinero
y yo gané mucho.
Al hacer eso, yo creí
haberme puesto a salvo
del riesgo de contagio.
Que no sólo al nivel del
pensamiento sobre mi relación,
sino que en la relación misma
había una surte de distancia irónica.
Algunas representaciones ficticias
hacen que experimentemos eso
con, al menos, una parte
de su contenido.
En Monty Python, cuando
vemos a Sir Lancelot
cortarle brazos y piernas
al Caballero Negro,
que se tambalea desangrándose,
no es el caso (supongo)
que haya ni siquiera un
pequeño riesgo de contagio
de pérdida de miembros.
Más bien, se adopta una
cierta actitud lúdica.
Al menos, hasta que se ve subvertida.
Uno de los estudiantes de esta
clase me llamó la atención
(y por buenas razones) en la
página de retroalimentación
debido a mis juegos en clase,
en el contexto de nuestra
discusión sobre el castigo,
en un ejemplo donde alguien
intentaba dispararle a otro
y fallaba o acertaba...
apenas un día después
del tiroteo de New Haven.
A veces, la realidad que
circunda una situación
hace casi imposible
(por la manera en que permea
nuestras respuestas no racionales)
adoptar una actitud lúdica.
Pero el hecho de que seamos
capaces de adoptar y desadoptar
esta actitud es, creo, algo de lo más
interesante e impresionante
sobre los seres humanos.
Lo que es innegable es que,
además de ser capaces de comprometernos
con este tipo de imitación
distante, lúdica y no habitual,
también podemos imitar algo
que lleve a un hábito.
Platón escribe: "Nuestros guardianes
han de imitar desde la niñez
cuanto les sea apropiado".
"A saber, a personas que sean
"valientes, templadas y pías.
"No deben ser astutos para lo
indigno, a menos que,
disfrutando de la imitación,
lleguen a disfrutar la realidad.
¿O no han notado que la imitación
practicada desde la juventud
se vuelve parte de la naturaleza y se
asienta a manera de hábitos,
gestos, voz y pensamiento?".
¿Locura acaso? Pues aquí
hay un artículo
que salió la semana pasada
en el New York Times
que habla sobre el
videojuego Madden NFL 12.
¿Alguno de ustedes lo juega en línea?
Excelente.
¿Qué característica de este juego
fue lo que llamó la atención
del New York Times?
Esto.
En la nueva versión del Madden NFL 12,
si un jugador sufre una contusión
es automáticamente eliminado del juego.
"Desde que la seriedad de las
contusiones se hizo evidente
a escala nacional", reza el
artículo del 2 de abril,
"el mensaje primario para los jóvenes
jugadores de futbol americano
es que sufrir una contusión
y ser retirado del campo por
el resto del día
es una de las cosas más difíciles de
aceptar y hacer para los jóvenes.
"Que la realidad será asistida
pronto por la fantasía"
(parece una paráfrasis de Platón),
"[se verá] en el Madden NFL
12, la próxima versión
del realista videojuego
jugado por millones,
que será tan realista para
no sólo mostrar
a los jugadores lastimándose,
sino para retratar cómo
cualquier jugador lastimado,
sin excepciones, queda fuera
del resto del juego".
Con lo que la fantasía sale al
rescate de la regulación social.
Aquí tenemos otro ejemplo.
¿Cómo entrenan las fuerzas
armadas de E.U.A. a sus soldados
para el campo de batalla?
Algo de lo que hacen es darles el
entrenamiento físico necesario
para tener la fuerza y
resistencia suficientes
para realizar ciertas acciones.
Pero uno de los principales
métodos de entrenamiento
es a través de videojuegos.
Con lo que tenemos un grupo de
soldados jugando un juego
inicialmente ideado para
el reclutamiento
del Ejército de Estados Unidos,
llamado America's Army.
Luego se desarrolló
para ser una herramienta de
entrenamiento para soldados.
Y acabamos con un grupo de soldados
jugando un videojuego como práctica.
He aquí un artículo del Washington
Post de hace algunos años.
"La realidad virtual prepara
soldados para la guerra real.
Una ardiente tarde en Irak,
combatiendo contra insurgentes
en el pueblo norteño de Mosul, el
sargento Sinkway Sualez
abrió fuego con su
ametralladora calibre 50.
Era sólo la segunda vez, dijo, que
le disparaba a un enemigo,
un enemigo humano al menos.
– Sentí que estaba en un
videojuego a gran escala, confesó.
– Ni siquiera me inmuté al
regresar el fuego.
Como si fuera un instinto natural.
'Pam, pam, pam', recuerda Sualez,
con voz acelerada y grave,
un virginiano fornido de 29
años de Chesterfield.
Sirvió como ingeniero de combate
en Irak por casi un año.
Y Sualez continuó:
– los insurgentes nos disparaban
desde el otro lado del puente.
Llamamos un helicóptero
para un ataque aéreo.
No pude creer que estaba viendo eso.
Era como Halo. No parecía
real. Pero lo era."
Más adelante en el artículo, el
reportero cita a un oficial del Ejército
de la oficina de Modelos y
Simulaciones de Defensa diciendo:
"La tecnología en los videojuegos
ha facilitado una revolución en
el arte de la guerra.
Cuando le llegó tiempo,–
refiriéndose a Sualez, dijo el
oficial–
de disparar su arma, estaba listo
y fue capaz de hacerlo.
Su experiencia anterior a ese momento
obtenida en su entrenamiento de campo
y jugando Halo y demás, le
permitió realizar el trabajo.
Su conciencia situacional estaba alerta.
Sabía qué tenía que hacer.
Ya lo había hecho antes o al
menos algo similar".
Empieza a parecer que el argumento de
Platón tiene su fuerza, ¿no?
¿Cómo es exactamente el argumento?
El argumento que hemos estado
considerando dice así:
Platón sugiere que la ficción afecta
las partes no racionales del alma
de tal manera que son
potencialmente desarmonizantes
respecto a la parte racional.
Esto es, que la ficción
puede hallar atractivas
cosas que no lo son para la reflexión
o encontrar cosas desagradables que
son agradables a la razón.
Por supuesto, puede también
hacernos cultivar cosas
que estén en armonía con
nuestros compromisos.
La terapia puede utilizar
las mismas técnicas
que el entrenamiento con
videojuegos del Ejército
para armonizar nuestras respuestas no
racionales con las racionales.
Pero es ciertamente un riesgo
que la ficción afecte
las partes no racionales del alma
de tal manera que desarmonicen
con la parte racional.
Nosotros, según Platón, deseamos
reflexivamente (por todas
las razones que hemos discutido en
la primera parte del curso)
poseer almas en armonía, en su
mayor parte al menos.
Cuando no nos hallamos
reaccionando por instinto
de maneras con las que estamos
reflexivamente a acatar,
nos cuesta y resulta poco deseable.
Podemos aventurar una salida
fácil a este problema;
basta con decirnos: "se trata sólo
de Halo, de un videojuego".
Pero no basta.
Los individuos, para Platón,
incluso los mejores,
no pueden regular estos efectos
internamente con su sola razón.
No podemos tener del todo bajo
control esas partes del alma
mediante la pura razón.
En cambio, dice, es posible regular
esos efectos externamente,
dejando que la sociedad tome
decisiones por nosotros
y decida a qué estaremos
expuestos y a qué no.
En consecuencia,
y es un argumento parecido
a los de Hobbes,
Platón sugiere en el libro X que
la racionalidad requiere,
dado nuestro reconocimiento
de sus límites,
estar dispuestos a restringir nuestra
libertad de alguna manera.
Al igual que Hobbes propugna que el
problema de coordinación
que surge con el dilema del prisionero
hace surgir la necesidad de
sujetarnos a un soberano
que tome el control y haga
cumplir los contratos,
Platón sugiere que
necesitamos sujetarnos
a una regulación por parte de la
reflexividad de aspectos
de nuestra experiencia que
nos afectan de maneras
que sabemos que son
peligrosas a la distancia,
pero que no están lo bastante lejos
como para protegernos de ellas.
Ahora bien, no es un argumento
fácil de asimilar.
Suscita toda clase de preguntas
sobre quién es el que ha de decidir.
O acerca de si la
manipulación no racional
es,
de hecho, un papel que
corresponda al Estado.
Pero también nos recuerda que,
si intentamos pensar qué
estructuras políticas
convienen a criaturas tan
complicadas como nosotros,
no habrá, al final,
respuestas fáciles.
En la clase del próximo martes,
comenzaré con una primera pregunta.
Que es ésta: ¿qué tiene que
ver esto con Sunstein?
Les dejaré, entretanto, las diapositivas
que tienen que ver con Sunstein,
de tal manera que, si quieren,
adelanten durante el fin de
semana cuál es la segunda:
¿cómo tiene lugar la persuasión
no racional en una sociedad?
Muchas gracias.
Y ya veré a aquellos de ustedes que
no visiten Bulldogs el martes.